Woher kommt der große rote fleck warum wird eher kleiner warum existiert ja schon so lange
der jupiter stellt uns vor große rätsel und jetzt ist noch eines hinzu gekommen seine polarlichter sie sind einfach riesenhaft und
Rekordverdächtig jetzt hat ein forschungsteam eine wirklich
mysteriöse entdeckung gemacht die die polarlichter des jupiter südpols betrifft
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler weltweit sind baff die aktuelle entdeckung gibt große rätsel auf welches verhalten der polarlichter
So mysteriös und warum es bislang gängige theorien komplett auf den kopf stellt jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Wir haben ja schon öfter mal über den riesenplaneten jupiter
Berichtet der uns immer mal wieder vor große rätsel stellt fest steht er ist wohl vom stärksten planetaren magnetfeld des
sonnensystems umgeben das sorgt zum beispiel dafür dass seine polarlichter sehr lebhaft und dynamisch sind seine augen
Leuchten vor allem, im ultravioletten. Im sichtbaren licht sind sehr unauffällig entdeckt wurden sie im jahr
1979 von der us raumsonde voyager 1 dennoch wusste waren lange nur wie die autoren der nordpolarregion
aussehen denn die sind von der erde aus tatsächlich sichtbar doch unser unwissen über den südpol des
jupiters hat die nasa raumsonde juno beseitigt sie war im august 2011 gestartet und waren juli
2016 in die umlaufbahn des jupiters eingeschränkt seitdem hat sie beispielsweise
infrarot aufnahmen von seinem nord und südpol gemacht und ihre messungen haben uns zum ersten mal auch die polarlichter an seinem südpol
offenbart sie enthüllten tatsächlich erstaunliches die energiereichen teilchen ströme und das magnetfeld verhalten sich komplett anders
Als bei den polarlichtern der erde jetzt kommt eine weitere
Wirklich mysteriöse erkenntnis hinzu ein forschungsteam aus london hat die beiden weltraumteleskope
xmm newton und shanda genutzt und den südpol von jupiter mehrere tage lang mit diesen beiden röntgenteleskop
Beobachtet das ergebnis auch hier gibt es ähnlich wie am nordpol ein gebiet in dem sich die röntgenstrahlung der polarlichter
konzentriert und das in einer mehr als
Beeindruckenden größe der jetzt entdeckte hotspot ist größer als die gesamte
Erde war und auch so lager dieses gebiets hat das forschungsteam
Erkenntnisse gewinnen können es liegt jeweils pohl werz von dem leuchtenden oval dass die im uv-licht sichtbaren
polarlichter bildet hinzu kommt eine weitere riesige überraschung denn das verhalten der jupiter polarlichter von nord- und südpol
Das ist komplett unterschiedlich einen großen unterschied macht ihre taktung statt wie erwartet
Im selben takt zu pulsieren pulsieren sie völlig unabhängig voneinander die südliche röntgen aurora pulsiert in einem elf minuten
Zyklus die messungen am nordpol dagegen ergaben dass die röntgenstrahlung dort entweder
Unregelmäßig auf strahlt oder aber in einem fünf bis acht minuten takt pulsiert
Also deutlich schneller als bei dem hotspot
Am jupiter südpol und das kommt wirklich mehr als überraschend und setzt die forschungsteams vor ein großes rätsel zitat wir dachten
Dass die aktivität der beiden voller licht gebiet durch das magnetfeld des planeten koordiniert wird sagt eine
beteiligten forscher william dann, zudem unterscheiden sich auch die licht kurven der strahlung
So das ergebnis der aktuellen studie nun gilt es die ursachen für diese rohren rätsel zu finden denn bisher galten die
wechselwirkung des sonnenwinds mit dem jupiter magnetfeld als auslöser der röntgenstrahlung und zwar in kombination mit den schwefel und
sauerstoff ionen die vom drittgrößten
Jupitermond io in die obere atmosphäre des jupiters gelang durch sein globales
magnetfeld nahm man bislang an dass die reaktionen dieses feldes
koordiniert ablaufen das forschungsteam
Vermutet jetzt dass noch weitere einflüsse an beiden polen würden die bislang aber noch unbekannt sind zitat wir müssen dies weiter untersuchen um herauszufinden
Wie der jupiter seine röntgen aurora produziert betont dann große hoffnungen setzt das team dabei auf die messdaten der
raumsonde juno
Wenn ihr erfahren wollt wie es da weitergeht und welche neuen erkenntnisse gibt und auch
Zu allen anderen themen die videos nicht verpassen wollte dann würden wir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesslich den
Genau auf die glocke denn dann kriegt er nur mit wenn neue videos online gehen hier geht es weiter mit jupiter
Fakten mit zahlreichen infos und spektakulären aufnahmen des größten planeten unseres sonnensystems und ansonsten bis dann
bleib dran